a little bit of a celebration before the
start of this game today
as the three starting all-stars in the
all-star game were honored
and they were out to acknowledge the
fans and there was a nice little video
on the board
16th start of the season for robbie ray
his seventh year at home he's won his
last two decisions his last one he won
his sixth the game of the season
robbie reyes set daddy chance and behind
the plate here's the first pitch cut on
it bounced toward third that's a fair
bulk having biggio across the diamond
one pitch one up
mandy rosarina moves up to the two spot
pound that strike zone good things are
going to happen
he's got that elite stuff and he's going
to pile up the strikeouts
first one of the days he strikes out of
rosa arena two down switch hitter
batting right-handed just 205 for the
season
ground ball up the middle simeon near
the bag
in time clean inning for robbie ray
ryan yarbrough will take them out today
for the tampa bay rays making his 12th
start of the season looking for win
number five
86 in the third innings of work so far
guerrero rips it past the third baseman
down the left field line it'll be extra
basis for guerrero
vladi gets things going for the blue
jays with the first hit of the ball game
is another
extra base hit a hard hit ball by
guerrero and now they have george
springer back
yarbrough on the one two half swing and
a miss he struck him out he's got
springer to go up and chase that pitch
and down goes springer he arms his first
strikeout
lead off man aboard in the second inning
this one is lifted into left a little
looper
that's gonna be a base hit diaz goes to
third and into second
meadows and the rays have something
cooking here in the
second inning now runners at second and
third nobody out
robbie needs a strikeout maybe you go
back to that high fastball
and he got it went right back upstairs
with the heater and strikes out zunino
here's the young catcher d.h today
francisco mejia
he swings and misses went right back to
the heater upstairs
two big strikeouts for ray that high
fastball especially with runners in
scoring position or runner third base
and less than two outs looks so
inviting to a hitter robbie ray trying
to pitch out of this gem
swinging a miss what a job one ball one
strike
hernandez is a short lead officials
running and the pitch is a strike throw
to second off line the tag out at second
base taylor walls grabbed it
on the backhand and snapped the throw
down and we'll see if the call holds
one out base is empty here's vizio
and a strike call to him
and he is out on strikes there's randall
grichik
randall with 14 homers and 54 rbis
six hits in 23 at bats against yarbrough
there's a high fly ball to the left
going back is meadows at the track at
the wall he jumps it's off the fence and
got
that ball went out of the ballpark and
hit the back fence so it's a home run
for randall
his 15th home run of the season and the
blue chase
take the lead another home run rosso is
in the lineup today he has a home run
against robbie ray
there's a wicked slide or no chance for
rosso swinging a miss that's four
strikeouts in a row five in the game
here's vlad guerrero
simeon off second base and it's way to
guerrero jr swung out and missed strike
three he tried to crush
and throws the bat down throws the
helmet down and he strikes out to end at
the blue jade third
now mike cena is struck out in the
second
it's his fly ball the left field not
deep curiel
ranging to his left is there and robby
ray again
pitches around the lead off double
francisco mahia the dh
he is a young switch hitting catcher
there's a fly ball into shallow center
kitchen coming in just a couple of steps
retired here's the shortstop taylor
walls he struck out on a slider his
first timer
ray has retired 10 of the last 11 rays
to come to the plate
sound as this is a high pop up into
shallow left field
gorilla the left fielder takes charge
and makes the catch
walls is retired two up two down
and he might have getting out of it
guerrero down to foul ground
he is there and makes another nice catch
body guerrero over the shoulder
bottom of the fifth inning looking at
randall grichik
and a cut in the miss richie
out on strikes with the backdoor cutter
84 outer third
swing and a miss one on one out in the
fifth for danny jansen
pitch in on janssen he pops it up and
here comes wald's hand with
yarborough ducking out of the way walls
made the catch
two gone top of the order simeon
the 2-2 delivery that is strength three
call and
nick marley gave brian yarbrough the
edge fifth strikeout for yarbrough
this is the third time for the rays to
face ray here this afternoon
and you can see that the numbers get
more favorable for the hitters each time
through the order
running again pitches high throw from
janssen's a good one and he throws out a
rosarena
danny jensen unloaded that high pitch in
a hurry
and he catches a base runner just the
second runner he's thrown out this year
terrific
throw
2-2 sky back into deep center grinch is
going to go to the wall and that one is
out of here
home run off the bat at wander franco
into the bullpen on a 2-2
pitch and the raids are on the board
they have tied this game
wander franco with his second home run
both have come as a right-handed hitter
and he pulls the
raise even so now the rays have the
potential
go ahead and run in scoring possession
with one out
one-one game in the sixth inning
austin meadows meadow shoots one into
right and that's gonna be over the head
of hernandez he came in on that ball
it gets over his head diaz is gonna head
to the plate and the throw will not be
in time
now down to third and out there is
meadows as the
rays take the lead diaz scores from
second to oscar hernandez
and there is a chase and he gets the
strikeout of hernandez
and he takes care of him on three
pitches i mean cutter cutter slider
this is why we call him nascar
everything
almost everything has a left turn
[Music]
[Applause]
popped into right rose arena is there
and makes the catch
column nicu with a couple innings under
his belt
and that pitch the fastball riding in on
him at 92.
maurice maguire will come on to pinch
hit
for janssen and a cut and a miss
and another strikeout five strikeouts
now
for mccues marcus simeone nothing of
three for the day
struck him up and calm the cube with
three shutout innings of relief
strikes out the side here in the eighth
great opportunity for the raise here to
add
now in the ninth inning that's a shot
into right field well
tagged that's gonna be off the wall will
bound away from hernandez
diaz scores and into second with another
double
that's meadows his third two base hit of
the day
and the rays pick up their third run
it's 3-1
tampa bay so men on the corners
taylor walls trying to add to the lead
and there's a shot into right that'll
get the job done
back toward the corner phillips trots
home
mahia will wind up at third
and a big hit by walls and the rays pick
up that extra run it's four to one
two outs with a man at third pay oscar
hernandez is the hitter
3-2 again and he pops it up this time
it's walls it's short waiting to make
the catch
and the rays are winners they pick up a
5-1 win in toronto to end the road trip